- Well what's the
girliest thing you've done
with your girls?
'Cause we have a lot of, like,
are they called girl daddy's?
I think that's what kind of the terms.
We've had a lot of them on
this show, and I love that.
- I'm involved in all
levels of what goes on,
but I'm under a lot of pressure
to have my toenails and
fingernails painted.
(audience laughs)
A lot of pressure.
- They're wanting you
to really get into that?
- There they are, yeah.
- I will be honest with you,
I've seen my husband paint
my daughter's toenails,
our eldest, when we first got together,
and he does a really good job.
(audience laughs)
- Like, better than me.
- I've found out
that I'm not bad at
braiding hair recently.
- He's good at that too.
Yeah, I don't know, he
had horses growing up,
so maybe because he did that
with their mane, I don't know.
- I'm terrible at it, braiding.
- Oh I can braid, I played sports.
- I'm really bad at the hair,
I'm good at the pretending.
So like the tea parties, and like,
when I'm cast as,
sometimes I'm stepmother,
or I'm, you know what I mean?
(audience laughs)
- I'm good
at the pretending stuff.
- That's creative,
I like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, but I'm not good
at the hair braiding
- How many kids do you have?
- Just one, one little girl.
- One little girl, how old?
- She'll be three.
- [Other Guest] Three,
awesome. Congratulations.
- Actually, isn't her birthday April 23rd?
- That's right.
- A day before mine.
- Get out of here.
- She's gonna be amazing.
- Taurus, Taurus women.
You'll let me know what I'm in for?
Please tell me.
(audience laughs)
- You know what, buckle up.
We're sweet until we're not.